et alors que l'organisation mondiale de
la santé dit lancer une initiative
historique pour accélérer la production
de vaccins et de traitements
la belgique elle accélère la confection
de blues médicale reportage à liège de
rafale blanc d'amour et david luiz
inouïe 6000 blues opératoire fabriqué en
trois semaines les petites mains de
l'opéra de liège ont mis de côté
perruques et costumes pour confectionner
des bourses de protection contre le
coronavirus une reconversion en réponse
à l'appel à l'aide du centre hospitalier
universitaire de liège qui craignaient
une pénurie de masques et de blues
derrière les rideaux derrière dans les
coulisses on continue à travailler
tenez compte que chaque jour je crois
que un opérateur
dans les hôpitaux en jette
trois ou quatre un look et sharks 3 au
gatt blues dont il
ils ont besoin de milliers de blouses
par jour papa semaine par joe des
employés qui découpe également du tissu
pour alimenter un réseau de plus de 2500
couturier bénévoles une véritable chaîne
de production solidaire s'est mise en
place
c'est la première fois que que nous
faisons ce genre de produit et je dirais
que c'est une de nos plus belles armures
qui nous était donnée de faire jusqu'à
maintenant si on peut apporter notre
petite pierre à l'édifice c'est toujours
c'est toujours important et intéressant
surtout dans les temps qui courent
au delà de la situation extrêmement
difficile dans les hôpitaux à prendre en
charge des patients qui étaient vraiment
critique et de toute la pression qu'on
avait effectivement par rapport au
manque d'équipements de protection
individuelle c'est elle en solidarité de
la population toutes les personnes parce
qu elle est couturière mais aussi les
chauffeurs tous les gens qui ont donné
de leur temps leur énergie pour venir en
aide aux soignants moi je trouve ça
magnifique objectif la fabrication de
20000 blues
cette mobilisation pourrait continuer de
fonctionner et aider d'autres centres
hospitaliers du pays